You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye and health conditions at early stages. To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an
你知道，你的眼睛经历了挺多的。每天看书啦、在昏暗光线下看东西啦，还有看屏幕时间太长啦，我经常这样。开车时强烈的阳光直射进眼睛。甚至夜间开车也会导致眼疲劳。所以，没错，我们的眼睛承受了很多。因此，照顾好它们、通过定期眼部检查来监测眼睛健康是很重要的。在Specsavers只需99澳元起即可进行眼部检查来检测眼睛健康，其中包括OCT眼部健康扫描，这有助于在早期阶段发现眼部及健康状况。要寻找离您最近的分店并预约起价99澳元的
OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.capsavers.c-a exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi, Angela. Hi, doll. What's up?
OCT扫描眼科检查，请访问specksavers.capsavers.c-a。眼科检查由独立的验光师提供。价格可能会因地点而异。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer），我是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极办公室爱好者播客。每周我们都会深入《办公室》的世界，带来独家采访、幕后细节以及许多闺蜜故事。我们是“办公室女郎6.0版”。嗨，安吉拉。嗨，亲爱的。怎么了？
Not much. We both dug out of our closet some really cute little jackets today. Today's the day of the cute jacket. My jacket I have had since before Isabel was born. And it's so cute. Is it still in style? It's kind of like a little bomber jacket? It feels in style?
没啥。我们俩今天都从衣橱里翻出了一些非常可爱的短夹克。今天是可爱夹克日。我这件夹克从伊莎贝尔（Isabel）出生前我就有了。而且它好可爱。现在还流行吗？它有点像那种小飞行员夹克？感觉还流行吧？
Sam's nodding. I mean, why would you ask me this question? I don't know. This is true. How would I know? This is true. This is what happens when two best friends neither have any fashion sense. We start advising one another. I like your jacket too. Thanks. I love it. I got it at that store. Oh, God, what's it called, lady? This is my brain. The Gap? No. Zara. No. Just keep naming stores until we get there. Anthropology. No, it's that one where you go in and they give you a little stylist. Like you go in and you... Macy's? No, the one where you go in and then you pick stuff out and then they style you where they like fill in all the blanks.
山姆（Sam）在点头。我是说，你干嘛问我这个问题？我不知道。确实如此。我怎么会知道？确实如此。这就是两个时尚品味为零的好朋友在一起时会发生的情况。我们开始互相给建议。我也喜欢你的外套。谢谢。我很喜欢。我是在那家店买的。哦，天哪，叫什么来着，女士？这就是我的大脑。Gap？不。Zara。不。一直报店名，直到我们猜到为止。Anthropology。不对，是那种你走进去，他们会给你配一个专属造型师的店。就像你走进去……梅西百货（Macy's）？不对，那种你走进去，挑好衣服，然后他们帮你搭配造型，帮你把所有空缺填满的店。
Wow, that sounds really cool. I did it in Oklahoma, every Eve, every Eve. Yes. I did it in Oklahoma City. Those ladies loved you. Yeah, I needed a blazer. I hadn't packed a blazer and Lee wanted to take me out for an early birthday dinner because he was going to miss my birthday last year. I mean, this is going all the way back to March.
哇，听起来真的很酷。我在俄克拉荷马州去过，Every Eve，Every Eve。对。我在俄克拉荷马城去过。那些女士们可喜欢你了。对啊，我需要一件西装外套。我没带西装外套，而且李（Lee）想带我出去吃一顿提前的生日晚餐，因为他去年要错过我的生日。我是说，这都得追溯到三月份了。
And I said, I'm just here for a blazer. and, you know, of course, they were amazing, and they put a bunch of cute stuff in my dressing room. Shout out to the ladies at Ever Eve in Oklahoma. Yeah. Well, first of all, I think we need to take a picture of us in these jackets. I agree. And do a little side-by-side. Oh, my gosh.
然后我说，我只是来买一件西装外套的。然后，你知道的，她们当然太棒了，在我的试衣间里塞了一堆可爱的衣服。向俄克拉荷马州的Every Eve的女士们致敬！对啊，首先，我觉得我们需要拍一张穿着这些夹克的合影。我同意。再来一个并排站立的合影。哦，天哪。
I know you love a side-by-side-by-side. It's not really a side-by-side. It's just a standing side-by-side. I like that, too. Well, we are kicking off this week's The Paper episode. It's episode six, journalism. And before we get to this breakdown, it's time for a quick little chit-chat. Don't worry, we are going to do around the town.
我知道你最喜欢各种并排站的合影了。其实也不是并排。就是站在一起的合影。我也喜欢那个。好了，我们要开启本周的《纸业公司》剧集了。这是第六集，新闻。在我们深入剖析之前，是时候来一段简短的闲聊了。别担心，我们等会儿会玩“环游小镇”。
We're going to get to that a little bit later. But first, let's hear this chit-chat suggestion from Darby in Iowa. Hey, office ladies. I absolutely love your podcast, and I'm so honored to be chosen to read my question for you guys today. So I'm not a conspiracy theorist, but I do find them fascinating to hear or read about. One of my favorite things about your podcast is when you do deep dives. It's fun to learn so much about random things. So my question for you guys is, was a conspiracy theory that you could be convinced as true?
我们稍后会聊到那个。不过首先，我们来听听来自爱荷华州的达比（Darby）提出的闲聊建议。嗨，办公室女郎们。我超级喜欢你们的播客，非常荣幸能被选中宣读我给你们提的问题。我不是阴谋论者，但我确实觉得听听或读读这些阴谋论非常迷人。我最喜欢你们播客的一点就是你们做深度剖析的时候。了解那么多随机的事情真的很有趣。所以我想问你们的是，有没有哪个阴谋论是你能被说服它是真的？
Or maybe you already have one that you believe in. I thought it would be interesting to hear what you guys come up with. Darby, we loved this suggestion. This both got our brains buzzing. It did. Did anything come to mind? You know we both have one. I don't even know what yours is.
或者也许你已经相信了其中某一个？我觉得听听你们会想到什么应该挺有趣的。达比，我们太喜欢这个建议了。这让我们俩的大脑都飞速运转起来。确实。有什么想到的吗？你知道我们俩都有一个。我都不知道你的是什么。
Okay, here's mine. Shall I go first? Sure. Darby, I'm a little obsessed with Stonehenge. Okay. So when I was in college, I did a semester abroad in London, and I signed up for this bus tour. We loaded up on a bus and we drove to Stonehenge. And I got goosebumps. It was like foggy. These things are huge. They're huge. I also took my yielded camera and I took tons of pictures. And then when I got back to my dorm room, I realized I hadn't put any film in it. I don't have a single picture. Well, what's the conspiracy about Stonehenge that it's arranged by like aliens or something? Like, what is it? When you go and see it, it's hard to imagine how these stones got there, how they got upright.
好吧，这是我的。我先说吗？当然。达比，我有点痴迷于巨石阵。好吧。所以当我在读大学时，我在伦敦做了一个学期的交换生，我报名参加了这个巴士旅行团。我们登上了一辆大巴，开往巨石阵。我起了一身鸡皮疙瘩。当时雾蒙蒙的。这些东西太巨大了。它们太巨大了。我还拿着我的胶卷相机拍了好多照片。然后等我回到宿舍时，我才意识到我根本没装胶卷。我连一张照片都没有。好吧，关于巨石阵有什么阴谋论吗？比如它是外星人什么的排列出来的？比如说，到底是什么？当你去参观时，很难想象这些石头是怎么弄到那里的，它们是怎么立起来的。
Does like nobody know how they got there? Well, there's a lot of like different theories and things. But the thing that I think really kicked off some conspiracy theories, at least from what I saw online, is in 2024, the science journal called Nature revealed that the six-ton altar stone at Stonehenge came from the northeast of Scotland and not whales like the rest of the monuments blue stones. Wait, there's one stone that's different than all the other stones. Yes, and it's a pretty fascinating revelation because it really ignited the question, how were the stones? Some weighing 45 tons transported and arranged to where they sit today. I mean, there was no basic transportation. The wheel hadn't even been invented. The wheel was like was invented five centuries.
难道没有人知道它们是怎么到那儿的吗？嗯，有很多不同的理论和说法。但是我认为真正引发一些阴谋论的事情——至少从我网上看到的来看——是在2024年，一本名为《自然》的科学期刊透露，巨石阵中那块重达六吨的祭坛石来自苏格兰东北部，而不是像该遗址其余的青石那样来自威尔士。等等，有一块石头跟所有其他石头都不一样？是的，这是一个非常迷人的发现，因为它真正点燃了这样一个问题：这些石头——有些重达45吨——是如何被运输并排列到它们今天所在的位置的。我是说，当时根本没有基础交通工具。连轮子都还没发明出来。轮子是在那之后五个世纪才被发明的。
later. Wait. What? Yeah, I know. So much of what scientists do know about the construction of Stonehenge is from educated guesses and constantly evolving research, the most recent of which suggests that, in fact, two of the largest boulders that make up Stonehenge have always been there where they sit today, but they don't know where the rest came from. And so theories are, if not aliens, perhaps giants. Giants! Yes! One of the earliest... We used to be a land of giants?
等等。什么？对，我懂。科学家对巨石阵建造过程的了解，很大一部分来自于有根据的猜测和不断发展的研究，其中最新的研究表明，事实上，构成巨石阵的两块最大的巨石一直都在它们今天所在的地方，但他们不知道其余的石头是从哪儿来的。所以大家的理论是，如果不是外星人，也许是巨人。巨人！是的！最早的名字之一……我们曾经是一片巨人的土地吗？
Listen, one of the earliest names for Stonehenge was, and I'm going to say it wrong, guys, Correa Gigantum, which has been interpreted by some as Giants' Dance. So, you know, I don't know. Is this like giving credibility to giants used to roam the Earth or aliens or who knows? But let me tell you, whoever arranged those, was an amazing engineer to make all that happen. But you feel it. When you're there in person, something feels like eerie, something extra.
听着，巨石阵最早的名字之一是——伙计们，我可能发音不准——Correa Gigantum，被一些人解释为“巨人的舞蹈”。所以，你知道，我不知道。这算是在为“巨人曾漫步地球”或“外星人”或者谁知道什么提供可信度吗？但我要告诉你，不管是谁排列了那些巨石，绝对是个了不起的工程师，才能让这一切成为现实。但你能感受到。当你亲临现场时，你会觉得有些诡异，有些不同寻常的东西。
It feels like this doesn't look like it should belong here. I got to go. It feels really old. Like I felt like when I went there, like I was entering a time I didn't belong in. It felt very old. Like, I felt the passage of time. from the earth. Wow. So there you go. I don't know, Darby. Like Stonehenge is fascinating to me. That is a conspiracy theory I can get sucked into. What about you, Jenna? Well, I had a hard time.
感觉这东西就不该属于这里。我得去看看。感觉真的好古老。就好像我去那儿的时候，感觉自己进入了一个本不属于我的时代。感觉非常古老。就像，我感受到了来自大地的岁月流逝。哇。所以就是这样。我不知道，达比。巨石阵对我来说太迷人了。那是一个我能深陷其中的阴谋论。你呢，珍娜？嗯，我有点难办。
I am such a naturally wired, skeptic, critical thinker. Yeah. When it comes to these things, nothing came to mind for me. So I instead Googled what are common conspiracy theories. And I, thought I could list them and maybe we could all just say if we could get sucked into them or not. Okay. All right. Matt, Sam, alien abductions. Oh. Yes, but I think a lot of the people that say they have them haven't had them.
我这人天生就是个怀疑论者、批判性思考者。是的。说到这些事情，我脑子里什么都没蹦出来。所以我只好去谷歌搜索常见的阴谋论有哪些。然后我觉得，我可以把它们列出来，也许我们大家都可以说说我们能不能被它们说服。行。好吧。马特、山姆，外星人绑架。哦。是的，但我认为很多说自己被绑架的人其实根本没有经历过。
Okay. But I do think it's feasible. All I can ever think of is that SNL sketch. Oh, the Kate McKinnon one. Yes. Basically, if you haven't seen it, Ryan Gosling, he gets abducted and he has the most magical experience. and they just, they surrounded me with love. And then Kate McKinning, like, has a cigarette.
好吧。但我觉得这确实有可能。我脑子里能想到的只有周六夜现场（SNL）那个小品。哦，凯特·麦金农（Kate McKinnon）演的那个。对。基本上，如果你没看过的话，瑞恩·高斯林（Ryan Gosling）被绑架了，他有了最奇妙的体验。他们只是……他们用爱包围了我。然后凯特·麦金农就抽起烟来。
She goes, yeah, that didn't happen to me. And they, like, came by and, like, swatted at her boobs. It's just hilarious. I'm sorry. Okay, go on. Matt, do you want to weigh in on alien abductions? I think they've happened. Okay.
她说，得了吧，我可没遇上这事。然后他们还走过来，拍了拍她的胸部。简直太搞笑了。不好意思。好吧，继续。马特，你想对“外星人绑架”发表点看法吗？我觉得这种事发生过。好吧。
To me, but I think they're out there. Matt, oh, we don't know very much about you. And I am already just like, ooh-hoo. I'm not big on it, but I could go with it. You could be made to believe. Here's where I'm thinking Darby is coming from. Like if one day one of these things was proven true, you'd be like, yeah, I see it. Yeah, fair enough.
对我来说，我觉得它们是存在的。马特，哦，我们对你了解真不多。而我此刻已经忍不住“哇哦”了。我对这个不在行，但我可以顺着这个想下去。你可能会被说服相信。这就是我觉得达比的想法来源：如果有一天这些事中的一件被证明是真的，你就会觉得，好吧，我懂了。行吧，倒也是。
Okay. JFK assassination, one shooter or multiple? Oh, my gosh. I'm one shooter. One shooter, but a lot of people planned it. I don't think Lee Harvey Oswald did it alone. I think he did it by himself. I think I'm a one-shooter guy here.
好吧。肯尼迪遇刺案，一个枪手还是多个？哦，天哪。我投一个枪手。一个枪手，但有很多人策划了这起谋杀。我不认为李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德（Lee Harvey Oswald）是独自干的。我觉得他是独自一人干的。我觉得我是个“单枪手论”支持者。
Oh. Huh. This one is tricky to me because I think it was one shot, but I always wondered why he was assassinated so quickly right after. That part always felt a little cover-up to me. Lee Harvey Oswald then being killed. Yes. Seems like a nice, like, tie it up with a bow.
哦。哈。这个对我很棘手，因为我觉得确实是一枪，但我一直纳闷为什么他在事发后不久就被迅速刺杀了。那部分我总觉得有点掩盖真相的嫌疑。李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德随后被杀。是的。感觉就像一个完美的、用蝴蝶结扎好的结局。
Yeah, it's too neat and tidy. All right. The moon landing was a hoax. No. No. The earth is actually flat. No. No. Then, you know, always that like somebody is still alive or faked their death, Elvis, Michael Jackson, Tupac.
对，太干净利落了。好吧。登月是个骗局。不。不。地球其实是平的。不。不。然后，你知道的，总有人说某某还活着或者假死，猫王、迈克尔·杰克逊、图帕克。
Yeah, I don't believe those. No. Okay. What about fake Melania? No, I just think it's just different makeup and styles. You know, she doesn't do a lot of public appearances as First Lady. So there has been a conspiracy theory that there's like a body double that shows up in like sunglasses and big hats for like short photo ops. And stands next to the president. But that, the person being replaced by somebody, that goes back to like the Beatles. Yes, Paul McCartney has been replaced by a lookalike is another conspiracy theory. Oh, wow. Yeah. Yeah.
对，我不信这些。不。好吧。那“假梅拉尼娅”呢？不，我只是觉得那是不同的妆容和风格。你知道的，作为第一夫人，她不怎么公开露面。所以一直有个阴谋论，说是有替身在一些短期的照片拍摄活动中戴着墨镜和大帽子露面。并站在总统旁边。但是，这种某人被替身取代的说法，可以追溯到披头士乐队。是的，保罗·麦卡特尼（Paul McCartney）被一个长相相似的人取代了，这也是另一个阴谋论。哦，哇。对。对。
Okay. What about the New Coke conspiracy? Do you know about that one? No. Do you remember back in our childhoods when Coca-Cola changed to New Coke? It was clear? No. No, that's Crystal Pepsi.
好吧。那新可口可乐（New Coke）的阴谋论呢？你知道那个吗？不知道。你还记得我们小时候可口可乐换成新可口可乐的时候吗？那是透明的吗？不对。不对，那是晶状百事可乐（Crystal Pepsi）。
That's crystal. That's different. But everyone got pissed off. They were like, we don't want New Coke. Yeah, nobody liked it. Right. That's what I remember. Because they were going to get rid of old Coke.
那是晶状百事。那不一样。但当时所有人都气炸了。他们说，我们不想要新可口可乐。对，没人喜欢。没错。这就是我记忆中的情况。因为他们打算把旧可口可乐停产。
Well, they did. They got rid of old Coke. They replaced it with new Coke. And then they, everybody got mad. So then they came out with Coca-Cola Classic. And for a while, you could buy either new Coke or Coca-Cola Classic. So the conspiracy is that they intentionally changed to an inferior product, new Coke, to drive up demand for the original Coke, which they then re-released with cheaper products and made more profit.
嗯，他们的确这么做了。他们停产了旧可口可乐。他们用新可口可乐取而代之。然后他们……每个人都很生气。所以后来他们推出了经典可口可乐（Coca-Cola Classic）。有一段时间，你可以买到新可口可乐或者经典可口可乐。所以阴谋论就是：他们故意换成了一种劣质产品——新可口可乐，来抬高人们对原版可口可乐的需求，接着他们再用更便宜的原料重新发布原版可口可乐，从而赚取更多利润。
See, that just seems pretty straightforward business to me. I'll buy that one. That seems like a little marketing-like strategy, but also it could just mean that someone shi-the-bed and then they had to scramble. Yeah. See, I can't get behind that conspiracy. I think it's more likely just poor business decisions. Yeah.
看，对我来说这听起来就是个挺直接的商业运作。我信这个。这听起来有点像营销策略，但也可能意味着有人搞砸了，然后他们不得不手忙脚乱地善后。对。你看，我没法支持那个阴谋论。我觉得这更可能只是糟糕的商业决策。对。
All right. Well, finally, this is my last conspiracy, and this is the one that I believed in. We finally got to my one. Oh, Bermuda Triangle. Now, what is the conspiracy? I think that it's got some kind of magnetic field that makes planes drop from the sky. Yeah. There's some kind of thing.
好吧。总之，最后，这是我的最后一个阴谋论，这也是我深信不疑的一个。我们终于说到我的那个了。哦，百慕大三角。那么，阴谋论是什么？我觉得那里有一种磁场，会让飞机从天上掉下来。对。某种类似的东西。
Like, I believe in it. Like, I believe that the Bermuda Triangle, I don't even know. Okay. But I would never fly over it. I'm not going to sail a ship into it. No way. Yeah. I think that's more superstition, though.
比如，我相信这个。比如，我坚信百慕大三角，我甚至说不清。好吧。但我绝对不会从它上面飞过。我也绝不会把船开进那个区域。绝对不。对。不过我觉得这更像是一种迷信。
But no, it's happened. All these ships and planes have been lost in the Bermuda Triangle, never to be seen or heard of again. Is that where Amelia Earhart went down? I don't think so. Yeah. It is? No. We don't know.
但不对，这确实发生过。所有这些船只和飞机都在百慕大三角失踪了，再也没有被看到或听到过。阿 Amelia Earhart（阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特）是在那里坠机的吗？我觉得不是。对。是吗？不是。我们不知道。
I'll tell you the Bermuda Triangle. It is loosely defined as a region in the North Atlantic Ocean bound by Florida, Bermuda, and Puerto Rico. And it kind of forms a triangle over sort of deep part of the ocean. Is it where Amelia Earhart went down? No, but there is a fringe conspiracy theory that I'm looking at it now. The Amelia Earhart-Bermuda Triangle theory. Conspiracy theory, yeah. It's a very fringe belief of that.
我来跟你说说百慕大三角。它大致被定义为北大西洋的一个区域，由佛罗里达州、百慕大和波多黎各界定。它在海洋深处上方大致形成了一个三角形。阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特是在那里坠机的吗？不是，但现在我正看着一个边缘阴谋论。阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特与百慕大三角的理论。阴谋论，是的。这是一种非常边缘的信仰。
Okay. Well, there you go. Darby, we dug into conspiracies for you. I hope you enjoyed it. That was fun for me. Yeah. Now, there is one conspiracy that I did not mention, and it's because it was a chit-chat suggestion, a single item to discuss in a future chit-chat. And I think we should save it, but it's Bigfoot. Oh, yeah. We could talk so much about Bigfoot. I know. And, you know, Lee did some deep dive research on Bigfoot. I feel like I need to get it in here. Okay, save. Yes. Oh, yes.
好吧。那么，就是这样。达比，我们为你深入探讨了阴谋论。希望你喜欢。这对我来说挺好玩的。对。现在，有一个阴谋论我没有提到，那是因为它是一个闲聊建议，是以后闲聊时讨论的单一项目。我觉得我们应该把它留到以后，不过那是关于大脚怪的。哦，对。我们可以聊好多关于大脚怪的话题。我知道。而且，你知道的，李对大脚怪做了一些深度研究。我觉得我得把它加进来。好吧，保留。太对了。哦，是的。
And let's have Lee come in. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we're going to get into season one, episode six of the paper, journalism. Yes. And writer Eric Rayhill, who also plays Travis, gave us some great behind-the-scenes details.
那让李进来吧。对。对。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？然后等我们回来，我们将进入《纸业公司》第一季第六集，新闻。是的。编剧埃里克·雷希尔（Eric Rayhill）——他在剧中也饰演特拉维斯（Travis）——给我们提供了一些非常棒的幕后细节。
He sure did. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Sometimes it can feel like everyone else has it all together. Their love life, even whether they're married or dating or single. Like, they've got it figured out. But the truth is, I think we're all still. figuring it out. No matter where you are in your romantic journey, therapy is kind of great because you have someone to talk it out with, get advice from, kind of help you determine what you want and take
他确实提供了。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。有时候，你会觉得好像只有自己状况百出，而别人的生活都顺风顺水。他们的爱情生活，无论是已婚、在恋爱还是单身，都安排得井井有条。就像他们已经把一切都搞定了。但事实是，我觉得我们其实都还在摸索中。无论你正处于情感旅程的哪个阶段，心理咨询都是一件挺棒的事，因为你有一个可以倾诉、获取建议的人，这能在某种程度上帮你确定自己想要什么，并为你卸下一些心理压力。
some of that pressure off yourself. Yeah, and maybe to help unpack some elements of the past that might be holding you back, well, BetterHelp therapists work according to a strict code of conduct. They are fully licensed in the U.S. And BetterHelp will offer you the therapist match commitment. You get a a short questionnaire, you say your preferences, and they'll match you with someone. But guess what? If you don't like them, you can switch to a different therapist at any time. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's betterhelp.com slash office ladies. 2025 was a great year for TV, movies, and music, and we are highlighted.
对，也许还能帮你解开过去中可能一直在拖你后腿的某些心结。嗯，BetterHelp的心理咨询师都遵循严格的行为准则。他们在全美都拥有完全的执照。而且BetterHelp会为你提供咨询师匹配承诺。你只需填写一份简短的问卷，写下你的偏好，他们就会为你匹配合适的人。但你猜怎么着？如果你不喜欢他们，你随时可以更换其他咨询师。拥有超过3万名咨询师，BetterHelp是全球最大的在线心理咨询平台，已为全球超过500万人提供过服务。注册并在betterhelp.com斜杠office ladies即可享受九折优惠。网址是betterhelp.com斜杠office ladies。2025年对于电视、电影和音乐来说都是伟大的一年，而我们重点介绍了其中的精华，包括K-pop恶魔猎人和《人生切割术》。我们将讨论今年我们最喜欢的时刻，包括一些你可能错过的最棒的流行文化。在任何你收听播客的地方搜索并收听“Pop Culture Happy Hour”。我们回来了。正如我们所说，本集是《造假新闻》（Churnalism）。由埃里克·雷希尔（Eric Rayhill）编剧，杰森·沃利纳（Jason Walliner）执导。杰森还执导过《圣丹尼斯医疗》（St. Denis Medical）、《南辕北辙》（Nathan for You）和《最后一个地球人》（The Last Man on Earth）。以下是剧情摘要：内德（Ned）接管了埃斯梅拉达（Esmeralda）的软文部门，并让他的员工亲自试用赞助产品，他认为此举将同时增强该报的利润和公信力。
the best of the best, including K-pop demon hunters, and severance. We're talking about our favorite moments of the year, including some of the best pop culture you might have missed. Listen to Pop Culture Happy Hour wherever you get your podcasts. We are back. As we said, this episode is Churnalism. It was written by Eric Rayhill and directed by Jason Walliner. Jason has also directed St. Dennis Medical, Nathan for you, and The Last Man on Earth. Here is your summary. Ned takes over Esmeralda's advertorial department and enlists his staff to personally try out sponsored products, believing the move will strengthen both the paper's profits and its credibility.
作为报复，埃斯梅拉达抢先报导了内德关于公园厕所关闭的故事，将其炒作成了一篇戏剧性的调查性揭黑报道，并由市长充当她的助手。这场原本被视为宣传噱头的行动，却意外地曝光了市政厅的一桩真实丑闻。我是说，如果你我能走上街头去质问市政厅的某个人并把他们抓个正着，那该有多好玩啊。我是说，我们待会儿会聊到这个，但我认为他们在这里做得非常出色。我知道。你知道的，我们问过埃里克，在剧中既当编剧又当演员是什么感觉，他是这么说的。他说，在这个工作之前我主要只是演戏，所以看到制作一部电视剧从头到尾需要付出多少心血，真的是太疯狂了。
Asmeralda retaliates by commandeering Ned's story about a park bathroom shutdown, blowing it up into a dramatic investigative expose with mayor as her sidekick. What begins as a publicity stunt unexpectedly exposes a real scandal at City Hall. I mean, you and I would have so much fun if you and I got to hit the streets and question someone at City Hall and bust them. I mean, we're going to get to it, but I thought they did an excellent job here. I know. You know, we asked Eric what it was like to be a writer and actor on the show, and this is what he said. He said, I've mostly just acted before this job, so it's really crazy to see how much it takes to make a TV show come to life from
成百上千的人。我是说，也许大家都知道这一点，但它确实太疯狂了。我当时就想到了这一点。我想起了我父母第一次来到《办公室》片场的时候。我爸当时就说，这么多人？对啊，爸，所有人都是。我是说，这就是为什么我们不想让AI取代演员的原因，因为你在项目中可能只看到寥寥几个演员，但在他们背后是成百上千获得就业机会的人。没错，搭建布景，还有——我是说，所有的这一切。对。制作一部剧或一部电影，真的是全社区共同努力的成果。是的。好吧，听着，这一集将从会议室开始。内德正在领导团队进行故事头脑风暴会议。
start to finish. Hundreds and hundreds of people. I mean, maybe everybody knows that, but it really is insane. And I thought about that. I thought about like the first time my parents came to the set of the office. My dad was like, all these people. Yeah, dad, all of them. I mean, this is why we don't want AI to replace actors, because you maybe only see a handful of actors in the project, but behind that are hundreds of people being employed. That's right, building sets and, I mean, all of it. Yeah. It's a real community effort to get a show or a movie made. Yes. Well, listen, this episode is going to start in the conference room. Ned is leading the team in a story brainstorming session.
埃斯梅拉达将推介一个关于史上最有效面部产品的报道。这是一个新产品。是一款来自韩国的面膜。对。她做了两张海报，其中一张上面印着这款Ulazang面膜，如果我发音正确的话。我在网上查了一下，这似乎是一个流行的韩国词汇，字面意思是“最美面孔”或“长相好看”。而且，你知道的，我一直在研究这些面膜。我试图找到一款与埃斯梅拉达推介的非常相似的面膜。
Esmeralda is going to pitch a story about the most effective face product in history. This is a new product. It's a face mask from Korea. Yeah. She has made two posters, and one of them featured. this Ulazang mask, if I'm saying that correctly. And I looked on the internet, and I guess it's a popular South Korean term, literally meaning best face or good looking. And, you know, I was looking into these face masks. And I was trying to find one that was very similar to what Esmeralda is pitching.
我没找到，不过我找到了一款在网上备受好评的产品。我买了几份，分别给我、你和山姆。我们今天显然不能直接敷。我希望你们回家去敷，然后向我汇报。哇。令人兴奋。准备好了吗？看这个。
I couldn't, although I found one that the internet is raving about. And I brought one for me, you and Sam. We obviously can't do them today. I want you to go home and do them, and I want you to report back. Wow. Exciting. Are you ready? Look at this.
这是什么？这是蒂佳婷（Dr. Jart+）申脉橡胶面膜。天哪，蒂佳婷很贵的。我知道。我是用我自己的钱买的。我没刷公司的信用卡。你们知道吗，我买的这款是紧致面膜。我们都要变紧致啦，各位。
What is it? It's a Dr. Jart plus Cairo rubber mask. Lady, Dr. Jart is expensive. I know. I bought it with my own money. I didn't use the company credit card. You guys, this one I bought is a firming mask. We're going to get firm, y'all.
我等不及了。这话听着怪怪的。好吧。总之，你们每人都有一个。好吧。海报上的另一款产品是一个下巴轮廓提升器。上面说这对男士来说是个改变游戏规则的产品。哦。
I can't wait. That's what she said. Okay. Anyway, you each have one. All right. The other thing on her poster is a jawline enhancer. It says it's a game changer for men. Oh.
嗯。我为我们俩找了一款。你得订购。需要花点时间。我没有买。哦。好吧，我很期待看看这个橡胶面膜到底有什么效果。嗯。
Mm-hmm. I looked for one for us. You have to order them. It takes a while. I don't have them. Oh. Well, I'm excited to just see what this rubber mask will do. Mm-hmm.
哇。看起来确实有点吓人。确实。我知道。我心里有点发毛。但内德对埃斯梅拉达的推介并不感冒。他说，我来给你们举个好新闻的例子。他今天骑自行车经过公园时，发现洗手间关门了。
Wow. It's very, it's a little creepy looking on that. It is. I know. I feel nervous. But Ned is not impressed by Asmeralda's pitch. he's like, let me give you an example of a great news story. He bicycled past the park today and the restrooms were closed.
他发现他们要把这些洗手间换成一个电动自行车租赁亭。怎么回事？这到底是怎么回事？为什么公园里不能有个洗手间？这把我逗笑了。妮可（Nicole）说，埃斯梅拉达的文章看起来像标题党。然后她说，内德的故事听起来就像我妈会发的那种莫名其妙的短信，而且不知道重点在哪。就是突如其来的。
He found out that they're going to replace those bathrooms with an e-bike kiosk. What's up? What's up with that? Why can't the park have a bathroom? This made me laugh. Nicole said, Asmorelda's article seems like clickbait. And then she said, Ned's story seems like something my mom would text and it wouldn't be clear why. It's just out of the blue.
太搞笑了。所以内德开始展现他那股“内德式”的傲慢。他有点居高临下地跟埃斯梅拉达说话。他把她的文章称为“垃圾新闻”（churnalism）。而且感觉就像，谁会从这种文章里学到任何东西？
It's very funny. So Ned has some Ned sass. He kind of talks down to Esmeralda. He calls what would be her article, journalism. And it was like, who's ever learned anything from such an article?
结果所有人都举起了手。他们都觉得自己学到了东西。对，内德说，我不知道“真理报”上有没有这种故事的容身之地。接着肯（Ken）毫无征兆地出现了。他说，其实，我可以跟你们讲一个我童年朋友的故事吗？
And everyone raised their hands. They all feel like they've learned something. Yeah, Ned says, I don't know if there's a place for this kind of story at the truth teller. And then Ken appears kind of out of nowhere. And he says, actually, can I tell you a story of my childhood friend?
我太喜欢这个故事了。我也很喜欢奥斯卡（Oscar）在这个互动中的表现，所以我希望我们能听听看。现在，我不知道我有没有跟你们讲过我童年的老朋友道格拉斯·基恩（Douglas Keane）。没有。所以道格拉斯是在加的夫的一座十居室庄园里长大的。听起来酷毙了。
and I loved this story so much. I also loved Oscar in this exchange, so I wanted us to hear it. Now, I don't know if I've ever told you guys about my old childhood friend Douglas Keane. No. So Douglas grew up in a 10-bedroom estate in Cardiff. Sounds sick as hell.
确实如此。谢谢你，特拉维斯。但你知道道格拉斯的父母是怎么买下加的夫这座十居室庄园的吗？不知道。有人知道吗？不知道。奥斯卡。纺织品？
It does indeed. Thank you, Travis. But do you know how Douglas' parents paid for this 10-bedroom estate in Cardiff? No. Anyone? No. Oscar. Textiles?
你说什么？纺织品。卖淫。天哪。算你答对了。卖淫。那么，我们就是道格拉斯·基恩。这座漂亮的办公室就是那座十居室庄园，
Pardon me? Textiles. Prostitution. God. I'll give you it. Prostitution. Well, we are Douglas Keen. This beautiful office is the 10-bedroom estate,
而这些——是的，稍微有点可疑的、标题党式的文章——就是在为我们出卖色相。没有了它们，“真理报”就会在黑暗中消亡。我就是——不知道为什么我这么喜欢这段。我真的很喜欢。这有一种很棒的会议室氛围，你知道的，大家都有这些简短的、自言自语式的台词，因为我也很喜欢特拉维斯在那段里的表现。是的。对。好吧，你知道的，我问过埃里克，他最喜欢为哪些角色写台词？他说巴里（Barry）和肯不相上下。他太喜欢他们了。对。我懂。我也一样。而且肯在本集里有一些非常棒的对话对句。我接下来会提到几个。好吧，内德说，好吧，那我们就做这篇关于美容产品的文章。事实上，
and these, yes, slightly dodgy, clickbait articles, are prostituting themselves for us. Without them, the TTT will die in darkness. I just, I don't know why I loved it so much. I did. It's just great conference roomy vibe, you know, where people have these little, like, one-off lines because I love Travis in that, too. Yes. Yeah. Well, you know, I asked Eric, who are his favorite characters to write for? And he said it's a tie between Barry and Ken. He loves them. Yeah. I get it. I do too. And Ken has some great couplets of dialogue in this episode. I'm going to mention a few as we go. Well, Ned says, fine, we'll do this article about this beauty product. In fact,
为什么我们不做一篇测试一大堆这类产品的文章呢？但我们必须以严谨和正直的态度来评测它们。嗯。这下埃斯梅拉达生气了。她觉得内德偷了她的故事创意。于是她说，好吧，那我就接手你那个无聊的厕所故事，让你看看怎么做。没错。所以在下一个场景中，内德走进办公区，手里拿着两个大塑料箱，
Why don't we do an article where we test a whole bunch of these products, but we have to review them with rigor and integrity? Mm-hmm. And now Esmeralda is mad. She's like, Ned just stole her story idea. So she's like, fine, I'll take your boring bathroom story and show you what. Exactly. So in the next scene, Ned enters the bullpen and he's got two big plastic bins
里面装满了供团队测试的免费产品。他说，你们在报道时必须保持中立和诚实。然后他开始分发。他给了妮可一些康普茶。巴里得到了这样一个牙齿美白仪，就是那种他塞进嘴里会发光的设备。奥斯卡将得到一款承诺无需做任何卷腹就能练出六块腹肌的产品。这随后引出了奥斯卡的一个单人访谈，我真的超喜欢，觉得我们应该听听。保证拥有六块腹肌。
full of free products for the team to test out. And he says you have to be neutral and honest in your reporting. And he starts handing him out. He gives Nicole some kombucha. Barry gets this like tooth whitening device, this thing he puts in his mouth and it lights up. Oscar is going to get a product that promises six-pack abs without a single crunch. And then this leads into an Oscar talking head, which I really loved and I thought we should hear it. Guaranteed six-pack abs.
不需要做卷腹。很显然，我知道这些东西不管用，但它们可能对我管用。这就是我。每次我看到愚蠢的Instagram广告，我就是这样。我知道。你会想：这个可能管用。我的意思是，明知这很蠢，然后我每次还是会把钱花在上面。而且，你知道的，埃里克跟我们分享过，这基本上就是本集的灵感来源。
No crunch is required. Obviously, I know these things don't work, but they may work for me. This is me. This is me every time I see a stupid Instagram ad. I know. You're like, this could work. I mean, I know that it's stupid, and then I just spend my money on it every time. And, you know, Eric shared with us that this was basically the inspiration for this episode.
他说，灵感大概来自于编剧室里大家在讨论我们都曾轻信过哪些（打引号的）“健康产品”。他说，我们很喜欢想象埃斯梅拉达为了拿免费的东西而推介这个主意。埃里克说，我曾迷信过那么多粉剂。天哪。Instagram广告把我拿捏得死死的。我知道。咱俩确实交换过信息。
He said, I think the inspiration came from the writer's room talking about what, in quotes, health products we've all fallen for. He said, we loved imagining Esmeralda pitching this idea just to get free stuff. Eric said, I've fallen for so many powders. Good God. Instagram ads have me in a chokehold. I know. You and I did trade messages.
当时我正在清理浴室，然后我说，这些是我再也不准自己买的东西。别再买颈部紧致霜了。歇歇吧。挑一个就行了。坚持用下去。比如，我有好多的面霜。你知道我不需要再买什么吗？发膜。
I was like cleaning out my bathroom and I was like, here are things I'm never allowed to buy again. No more neck firming cream. Give it a rest. Pick one. Stick with it. Like, I have so many creams. You know what I don't need another one of? A hair mask.
我哪有时间在头上搞这些？我洗完头，还得抹上发膜，然后等10到15分钟，接着还得回浴室冲掉。这在我生活中根本不可能发生。你知道我买了什么吗？什么？我买了那种脚膜。就是把脚塞进去的袋子。
When do I have time to put something on my head? I wash my hair, then I have to put a hair mask on, and then I wait 10 to 15 minutes, and then I have to get back in the shower. This is never happening in my life. You know what I bought? What? I bought these pouches. You stick your feet in.
就像足膜一样。哦，我超喜欢那个。我和女儿特别喜欢敷着那个然后看电影。我们经常搞什么“电影院水疗之夜”。他们也有手膜。我知道，但够了。你知道我的意思吗？它们能用好久呢。
It's like a foot mask. Oh, I love those. My daughter and I love to put those on and then watch a movie. We do like movie spa night. They have them for your hands, too. I know, but I'm good. You know what I'm saying? Like they last forever.
好吧。我不需要再买啦。好吧。现在市长要走进埃斯梅拉达的办公室了，她说，我是来协助你的。内德觉得我能帮上忙。然后你懂他们的动态会是怎样的。埃斯梅拉达将掌控全局。
Okay. I don't need to buy anymore. Okay. Well, Mayor is now going to go into Esmeralda's office and she's like, I'm here to like assist you. Ned thought I could help you out. And then you know what their dynamics going to be. Esmeralda's going to run the show.
现在她有了自己的“周五男仆”。对了，你看到她在看什么书了吗？我是说，她对待这事非常严肃。我把镜头放大看了。当市长进入她的办公室时，她正在看一本名为《基础新闻学：探索基本原理》（Basic Journalism Exploring the Fundamentals）的书，这是一本针对大学生的综合性学习教材。哇，我当时没注意到。好吧，不管怎么说，这是一本真书。
And now she has her guy Friday. Well, did you see the book she's reading? I mean, she's taking this very seriously. I zoomed in on it. When Mayor enters her office, she's reading a book called Basic Journalism Exploring the Fundamentals, a comprehensive study book for university-level students. Wow, I did not catch that. Well, for what it's worth, it's a real book.
哇。好吧，现在亚当（Adam）要测试某种类型的蘑菇，但肯迅速走进来，把那些扔掉，递给他这个小包，并说：给，把这些药片吃了。你知道的，它们就像是一种补剂。而亚当甚至都没看包装，就把药片吃下去了。搞什么鬼？对。还有一个小包。
Wow. Well, now Adam is going to test maybe some type of mushrooms, but Ken quickly comes in, tosses those out and gives him this packet, and he's like, here, take these pills. You know, they're like a supplement. And Adam, without even looking at the package, takes the pills. What the hell? Yeah. And there's this packet.
是从鲁迪（Rudy's）加油站买的，叫“蝎子刺”（Scorpion Sting）。里面某种类似……男性保健品。男性保健品。对。这会增加他的精子数量什么的。亚当瞬间慌了。他说，哦，天哪，我可不能让我老婆再怀孕了。
It's called Scorpion Sting from Rudy's gas station. There's some type of like... Like male enhancement. Male enhancement. Yeah. It's going to pump up his sperm count or something. And Adam's instantly worried. He's like, oh, God, I can't get my wife pregnant again.
他们有四个孩子。对。我对亚当有几个问题。是什么？第一，你在吃之前怎么不看一眼自己吃的是什么？什么？第二，他居然一口水都没喝就把药吞下去了。
They have four kids. Yeah. I have a few questions for Adam. What are they? One, you don't look and see what you're, you're taking before you take it. What? Two, he quickly downs them with water.
幸好喝了水，不然如果他干咽下去，我会觉得超级反胃。好吧。看到别人不喝水直接吞药片，你也会觉得反胃吗？我的强迫症之一就是电影里那种情节：人们打开处方药瓶，然后倒出一大把药片。就像他们很痛一样，他们不按照规定的剂量吃，而是把一堆药一把塞进嘴里，
Thankfully, because if he drank them without water, it'd make me cringe. Okay. Does that make you cringe when people, like, take pills without water? One of my pet peeves is movies where people open up a prescription pill bottle and then they pour, like, just a bunch of pills. Like, they're in pain, and they don't, like, take the prescribed amount, and then they just put them in their mouth. and then they just like, they chuck their head back and just swallow them dry.
然后他们就把头往后一仰，直接干咽下去。乔希（Josh）吃维生素就是这样的。别这样。什么？他直接把它们塞进——天哪？是的。然后我就想，对不起。到底怎么做到的？我可做不到。
Josh takes his vitamins like that. Don't. What? He just puts them in the hell? Yes. And I'm like, I'm sorry. How in the hell? I can't do that.
而且他每次这么做，都让我直作呕。哇。总之，最后，亚当，去结扎吧。咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓。把这事了结了吧。好吧，他说他老丈人不信避孕。那这也算避孕吗？对，我对此也有个疑问。
And every time he does it, it makes me want to gag. Wow. Anyway, lastly, Adam, get a vasectomy. Snip, snap, snip. Shut it down. Well, he says his father-in-law doesn't believe in birth control. Would that be considered birth control? Yeah, I also have a question about that.
你老丈人怎么会在你的婚床里？他怎么对你们的事了如指掌的？到底是谁在向你老丈人汇报？哦，我们这个月不戴套。这到底是谁在汇报工作？别去汇报了。我不知道。听起来他们跟她父母的关系纠缠得太深了。
How is your father-in-law in your marital bed? How does he know your business? Who's telling your father-in-law? Oh, we're not using condoms this month. Like, who's reporting back? Don't report back. I don't know. It sounds like they have a very emmeshed relationship with her parents.
这让我觉得有点毛骨悚然。好吧，所以在下一段里，奥斯卡拿到了这个腹肌仪，对吧？它好像绑在腰带上，或者类似的东西，他把它绑在腹部。看起来像一个个小东西，看起来像脉冲装置。对，它们看起来像做心电图时贴的那种小贴片。没错。或者我们其实也有这种小东西，可以贴在紧绷或痉挛的肌肉上。
It's creeping me out a little bit. Okay, so in the next bit, Oscar, he gets this ab device, right? It's like on a belt, it looks like, or something you, like, puts it around his abdomen. It looks like little, it looks like, pulsing things. Yeah, they look like little stickers like when you're getting an EKG. Right. Or we actually have these little things you can put on a muscle that's like tight or locked up.
乔希有这种东西，它们能给你小幅度的脉冲。对。它们有助于锻炼。就像我得网球肘时，那个太神奇了。哦，对。我以前做物理治疗时也用过这个。对。对。
Josh has them and they give you little pulses. Yeah. And they help work out. Like when I had tennis elbow, it was amazing. Oh yeah. I've had that from a physical therapy before. Yeah. Yeah.
所以它有点像那样。他把它贴在腹部。我想这应该是为了帮你练出六块腹肌。他把档位调到了三级，然后痛苦得不行。他说，然后阿黛洛拉（Adelola）走过来，她说，我要把它贴上，因为这不可能比痛经还疼。基本上，奥斯卡一直在往上调档位，直到调到九级，她才说：“好吧，好吧，这确实有点疼。”对。然后他说，天哪。
So it's kind of like that. He's put it on his abdomen. It's supposed to, I guess, like help you get a six pack. he puts it at a level three and he's in so much pain. He's like, and then Adelola walks up and she's like, I'm going to put it on because it can't be any more painful than cramps. Basically, Oscar keeps turning the notch up and it isn't until level nine that she like is like, okay, yeah, that kind of hurts. Yeah. And he's like, holy crap.
对。然后他把档位调到了九级，在椅子上浑身抽搐。太精彩了。我真的得为奥斯卡在这个场景中的形体喜剧表现起立致敬。我们还收到了一位来自德克萨斯州达拉斯的粉丝雅斯敏·Y（Yasmin Y）的问题，她说道：向奥斯卡在《办公室》大结局里的腹肌锻炼致敬，太棒了。是的，雅斯敏，我的想法跟你一样。
Yeah. And so then he puts it on at a nine and he's like convulsing in the chair. It's amazing. I really need to give Oscar a standing ovation. for his physical comedy in this scene. We also got a fan question from Yasmin Y in Dallas, Texas, who said, great callback to Oscar and the ab workouts from the end of the office. Yes, I thought the same thing, Yasmin.
我猜奥斯卡一直对腹肌小玩意儿情有独钟。我回看了《办公室》第九季的那一集。那是《向前看》（Moving On）那一集，奥斯卡为此有一个单人访谈。我想让你们听听。我在网上看的广告太多了，仰卧起坐却做得不够。所以我买了这些。现在，每当网上跳出广告，我就有30秒的腹肌暴击时间。我称之为“广告换腹肌”。
I guess Oscar has always been a sucker for ab gadgets. I went back to the episode from the office in season nine. It's the episode moving on, and Oscar has a talking head about it. I want you to hear it. I watch way too many ads online, and I don't do enough sit-ups. So I bought these. Now, every time an ad pops up online, I get 30 seconds of ab blasting. I call it ads for abs.
所以他一直想练出六块腹肌。总之，这太逗了。而且，我最近跟奥斯卡合作过。你们很快就会看到是什么了。跟《纸业公司》没关系，但挺好玩的。对。我们在两个场景之间闲聊。珍娜，你和我当时正在发信息讨论这个特定的场景。
So he's always wanted to get a six-pack. Anyway, it just cracks me up. And, you know, I recently worked with Oscar. You'll see what it is soon. It's nothing to do with the paper, but it was fun. Yeah. But we were between scenes. And Jenna, you and I were texting about this specific scene.
所以我当时就说，奥斯卡，我们必须了解一下这个腹肌神器，因为看起来你当时非常痛苦。你当时到底在干嘛？它真的在掐你还是怎么的？然后他说，哦，没有，那只是一些微小的脉冲。一点也不痛苦。他说那全都是演的。事实上，当档位调到九级时，
So I was like, Oscar, we got to know about this ab contraption. because it looks like you're in a lot of pain. Like, what were you doing? Was it really kind of pinching you or something? And he said, oh, no, it was just these tiny little pulses. It wasn't painful at all. He said that was all acting. In fact, when it goes up to the level nine,
我本来想让他们在我的桌子上放一个枕头，因为我想把头往桌子上撞。但我想了想，好吧，也许那样太夸张了。我真不敢相信它居然真的起作用了。我一直以为是假的。不，他说那只是一些微小的刺激，但他的反应全都是他自己的。好吧。
I wanted them to put a pillow on my desk because I wanted to slam my head on my desk. But I was like, okay, maybe that's too much. I can't believe it actually was doing something. I just assumed it was fake. No, he said it was like tiny little. things, but his reactions were all his own. All right.
好吧，现在德里克（Detrick）要进行单人访谈了，他戴着他本应测试的设备。那是个下巴轮廓定型仪。就像一个戴在脖子上的红色LED设备。我在网上查了。有很多类似的版本。哦，对了，你带了吗？带了，女士。
Well, now Detrick is going to have a talking head, and he's wearing his device that he's meant to be testing. It's like a jawline defining device. It's like a red LED thing that you put on your neck. I looked online. There are several versions of things like this. Oh, well, did you bring one? Yes, lady.
你买了一个？我给我们俩买了一个。等等，你买这个纯粹是因为这一集吗？嗯哼。哦，天哪。我整个早上都在给它充电。等等，基本上我买的是紧致面膜，而你买的是。
Have you bought one? I bought one for us. Wait, did you buy this just because? of this episode? Uh-huh. Oh my gosh. I've been plugging it in all morning. Wait, basically I got us firming facial mask and you got us.
这个东西。这个下巴带子。对。来，我把它戴上。好了。准备好了吗？嗯。好吧。
This thing. This chin strap thing. Yeah. Here, I'm going to put it on. All right. Ready? Yeah. Okay.
猜猜这玩意儿多少钱？40美元。21美元。哦，天哪。我的面膜价格也差不多。你觉得怎么样？看起来不错，女士。真的很好看。
Guess how much this was? $40. $21. Oh my gosh. My face mask costs the same. What do you think? Looks good, lady. It looks really good.
我觉得你应该戴着它录完这一集。太棒了。看看你有什么感觉。好的。到最后。到时候你告诉我我的脖子看起来是不是更紧致了。好的。宣传册上是这么说的。它说红光疗法拥有广泛的应用范围和健康益处。此时此刻，你让我想起了我的孩子们拔完智齿时，他们用这种冰袋似的东西裹住下巴的情形。上面说这种波长在管理急性和慢性疼痛状况（如运动损伤、关节痛和炎症）方面特别有效。
I think you should wear it for the entire episode. Great. See how you feel. Okay. at the end. You tell me if my neck looks firmer at the end. Okay. Here's what the brochure says. It says red light therapy boasts a broad spectrum of applications and health benefits. Right now, you're reminding me of when my kids got their wisdom teeth out and they wrapped their chin with this like ice pack thing. It says that the wavelength is particularly effective in managing acute and chronic pain conditions like sports injuries, joint pain and inflammation.
我觉得你应该在整期节目都戴着它。太好了。看看你感觉如何。好的。最后。你告诉我最后我的脖子看起来是不是更紧致了。好的。这是宣传册上写的。上面说红光疗法具有广泛的应用范围和健康益处。现在，你让我想起我孩子们拔智齿时，他们用这种冰袋似的东西把下巴包起来的情形。上面说这种波长在治疗急性和慢性疼痛（如运动损伤、关节痛和炎症）方面特别有效。
but it also improves blood circulation and alleviates pain and stiffness giving me a headache, taking it off. Ow. I don't want it. Okay. I'll just have a saggy chin. Lady, I'll have one with you. Why don't we take a break because us and our saggy chins have more fun stuff to discuss.
但它也能改善血液循环，缓解疼痛和僵硬，结果把它拿下来的时候把我弄得头疼。噢。我不想要它。好吧。那我只能顶着个双下巴了。妹子，我跟你一样。我们为什么不休息一下呢，因为我和我们的双下巴还有更有趣的事要讨论。
We are back from break. Before we get back to more of the paper, it is time for around the town, which I really think we need a sting for. Yes. Right? I want to go back to Ye Olden times when we had a sting. Sam? On it. Yay. Angela, kick us off. I will. This is from Josie W. in Syracuse, Utah. I'm so tickled by this, okay? Okay. Listen to this. What? Josie says, it's bald eagle season in northern Utah, exclamation point. Bald Eagles migrate from the mountains and from colder northern regions, and one of them comes to my little neighborhood every year. During January and February, we see him flying around the pond, perched on phone lines, and flying over our house.
我们休息回来了。在我们继续看报纸之前，是“漫步小镇”环节，我觉得我们真的需要一个转场音效。对啊。对吧？我想回到过去有转场音效的日子。萨姆？在弄了。耶。安吉拉，你来开个头。好的。这是犹他州锡拉丘兹的乔茜·W发来的。我真的被这个逗乐了，好吗？好。听听这个。什么？乔茜说，犹他州北部迎来白头鹰季啦，感叹号。白头鹰从山里和更寒冷的北方地区迁徙过来，每年都会有一只来到我住的小社区。在一月和二月，我们会看到它在池塘周围飞翔，停在电话线上，从我们房子上方飞过。
I'm a birder, and seeing a bald eagle so close and in my literal neighborhood is easily one of my favorite times of the year. I love that it's the same one that keeps coming back. It makes me so happy. Remember when I had those ducks that would come and hang out in my pool a few years in a row? When I was a kid, my parents had a Purple Martin house in the backyard, and we would just, wait for the Purple Martins to come each season. Look at that. I never knew that about you.
我是个观鸟爱好者，能这么近距离地看到白头鹰，而且就在我实实在在的社区里，这绝对是我一年中最喜欢的时光之一。我喜欢每年回来的都是同一只。这让我太开心了。还记得几年前，我家里连续好几年有那些鸭子来游泳池边晃悠吗？我小时候，我爸妈在后院里装了一个紫蓝罗燕的鸟舍，我们就只是等着紫蓝罗燕每个季节飞过来。你瞧。关于你，我以前从来不知道这件事。
Yeah. Now, when I see your parents, I'm going to say, you know, how's the Purple Martin business going? Well, it's not going great. They moved. They brought the Purple Martin house with them. I mean, it's not like they moved to a whole new state or anything. They just moved across town. Yeah.
对啊。现在，我要是见着你爸妈，我就会说，你知道的，紫蓝罗燕的生意最近怎么样啊？嗯，情况不太好。它们搬走了。它们把紫蓝罗燕的鸟舍也一起带走了。我是说，又不是搬到全新的一州什么的。它们只是搬到了镇子的另一头。对啊。
No. I know my ducks moved too. Okay. Well, Josie, I loved that. All right. Next one is from Izzy A in Philadelphia. Pennsylvania. Izzy says, I was part of a live podcast recording event in my neighborhood of West Philly, in quotes, best Philly, about the local Yiddish cultural community. I am part of a group of
没。我知道我的鸭子也搬家了。好吧。嗯，乔茜，我很喜欢这个。好啦。下一个来自宾夕法尼亚州费城的伊齐·A。伊齐说，我参与了西费利（West Philly）——用引号说，“最棒的费利”——我住的小区里的一场现场播客录制活动，主题是当地的意第绪语文化社区。我是其中一个群体的一部分，
people who are learning Yiddish to reconnect to our ancestral language and also do Yiddish music, dancing, and theater. I'm currently organizing 53 people in Fiddler on the roof in Yiddish. Oh my gosh. And I got to talk about that on the podcast. I'm I'm proud that my little neighborhood has this much interesting culture and art going on. I love that. And Jenna, you were in Fiddler on the roof. Lady, I was the fiddler on the roof. In high school, the musical, I was the fiddler. It was the lead, the lead dance role, because I was only ever in the dance chorus. I never broke out. You're a very good dancer. Well, I mean, I was. You know, like, every once in a while, there'll be a little song on and you get your little hips way and little, you do some like toe tacks. tapping things. Well, I was trained in Bob Fosse. Oh. It's a way you move your hips. That's a
我们在学习意第绪语，以重新连接我们的祖先语言，同时还做意第绪语的音乐、舞蹈和戏剧。我目前正在组织53个人排练意第绪语版的《屋顶上的提琴手》。噢，天哪。我居然能在播客里聊这个。我为我的小社区有这么多有趣的文化和艺术活动而感到骄傲。我太喜欢这个了。珍娜，你演过《屋顶上的提琴手》。妹子，我就是屋顶上的提琴手。在高中音乐剧里，我就是那个提琴手。这是领舞，核心舞蹈角色，因为我以前只跳过舞蹈合唱。我从来没有脱颖而出过。你是个很好的舞者。好吧，我是说，我曾经是。你知道的，就那种，偶尔会放一首小歌，然后你就会扭动你的小屁股，做一些脚尖轻叩的动作。拍打动作。嗯，我是受过鲍勃·福斯（Bob Fosse）训练的。哦。这就是你扭动屁股的方式。这可真是在炫耀啊。
flex. A little bit of a flex. But yeah, I had the lead dance role in Fiddler on the Roof. My dad's favorite joke. This is such a dad joke. He was like, you know what, sweetie, without you, it would just be called the roof. That show needed you. That's adorable. So cute. Well, Izzy, that was fantastic. Next up is Kelly M from London, UK. Kelly says, Dear ladies, happy new year. In news from London, I visited the Marie Antoinette style exhibition
稍微炫耀了一下。不过对啊，我确实在《屋顶上的提琴手》里跳了领舞。我爸爸最喜欢的笑话。这太像爸爸讲的笑话了。他说，你知道吗，亲爱的，如果没有你，这剧就只能叫《屋顶》了。那场演出需要你。这太可爱了。太可爱了。好吧，伊齐，那太棒了。接下来是来自英国伦敦的凯利·M。凯利说，亲爱的女士们，新年快乐。关于伦敦的新闻，我昨天去V&A博物馆参观了玛丽·安托瓦内特风格展览。
at the V&A Museum yesterday. It was wonderful. Items actually used by the queen, chairs, desks, tea sets, finishing with a room filled with modern designs inspired by her. 10 out of 10, recommend. Lots of love to you and the pod team from London. this is making me want to get on an airplane right now and see this exhibit.
太精彩了。有女王实际使用过的物品、椅子、书桌、茶具，最后是一个摆满了受她启发而设计的现代作品的展厅。10分满分，强烈推荐。把满满的爱送给你们和伦敦的播客团队。这让我现在就想坐上飞机去看看这个展览。
I want to see the T-set. I want to see it all. I want to see it all, but I need to see the T-set. No. We're going to go to London. Are we? Office ladies in London! Lady, we are having a hard time planning our one-day work retreat in town.
我想看那套茶具。我什么都想看。我什么都想看，但我必须看到那套茶具。不。我们要去伦敦。真的吗？办公室女士在伦敦！妹子，我们在规划镇上一日工作静修会时都遇到困难了。
I know. How are we going to London? Well, we're busy. We have five kids between the two of us. I know. We're busy. But, I mean, Kelly, I'd love to get there. Thanks for sharing.
我知道。我们要怎么去伦敦？嗯，我们很忙。我们俩加起来有五个孩子。我知道。我们很忙。但是，我是说，凯利，我很想去那儿。谢谢分享。
Thanks for writing in with your. around the towns. Let's get back to the episode. Next up, Detrick lets us know that Nicole is really struggling. I guess the kombucha that she drank was supposed to be refrigerated. She's not going to have a good time. She's going to spend a lot of this episode in the bathroom. Yes. Like, you know. And as Morelda calls Frank Durham, the administrative manager of McGundry Park. And he's very dismissive towards her. He is. Yeah. He says, listen, that's what's happening. But Esmeralda is not dissuaded. In fact, it emboldens her.
谢谢你们写信来分享身边的趣事。让我们回到这一集。接下来，迪特里克告诉我们尼科尔真的遇到大麻烦了。我猜她喝的康普茶应该是要冷藏的。她这下有好果子吃了。她这集得花大把时间待在卫生间里了。没错。就像，你知道的。当埃斯梅拉达（Esmeralda）去找麦甘德里公园（McGundry Park）的行政经理弗兰克·达勒姆（Frank Durham）时。他对她非常轻蔑。确实如此。对。他说，听着，事情就是这样。但埃斯梅拉达没有被吓退。事实上，这反而给了她更多勇气。
She's like, you know what? There's a story here. She thinks he was being dodgy on the phone. Yeah. So her and mayor are going to go down to the city hall offices. And do some digging. Yeah. They go tell Ned who has this insane blue face mask on his face.
她心想，你知道吗？这背后有故事。她觉得他在电话里闪烁其词。对。所以她和马尔（Mar）打算去市政厅办公室。然后挖点料。嗯。他们去告诉内德，而内德脸上敷着超级夸张的蓝色面膜。
Honestly, it looks like the blue version of the mask you bought us. Lady, this is what inspired me to get this mask is Ned's blue mask. And guess what? You can get a blue one. It's like hydration, but I thought we should get the firming quad. What are you saying? What are you implying? That's what we ever talk about is like, how do we firm up our wobbles?
老实说，这看起来就像你给我们买的那款面膜的蓝色版本。妹子，我买这款面膜就是受了内德蓝色面膜的启发。你猜怎么着？你也能买到蓝色的。这就像是补水面膜，但我本来觉得我们应该买紧致四重奏的。你在说什么？你在暗示什么？我们平时聊的不都是，怎么把我们的松弛部位变紧致吗？
Anyway, Sam, sorry to lump you in that. Nope, I'm good. Well, all of Hollywood is firming up their wobbles. They're doing all the things and we have done nothing. What do they call it now? You look snatched. Oh, snatched. You look snatched.
不管怎样，萨姆，抱歉把你也扯进去了。没事，我挺好的。好吧，整个好莱坞都在把他们松弛的部位变紧致。他们把所有能做的都做了，而我们什么都没做。他们现在管这叫什么来着？你看上去被“揪”紧了。哦，紧致。你看上去很紧致。
We're not snatched. Your neck is all like, ten. Tight. What's the term if you're not snatched? Us. Office ladies. But here's my question. When you snatch up your face like that, when you do all that, right? Yeah. What about your hands? Do you still have old lady hands? Or are you snatching your hands? Here's what I told you when we were talking about this. I said, I feel like it's like my house. My house is an older house. Well, guess what? We've got a leak in Cade's bathroom. It's going to have to be gutted and redone. And now Kate's bathroom is going to look amazing.
我们可不紧致。你的脖子整得像个十岁的。紧绷。如果不叫紧致，那个词叫什么？我们。办公室女士。但我的问题是。当你像那样把脸往上提拉，当你把这些都做完之后，对吧？对。那你的手怎么办？你还是有一双老太太的手吗？还是说你连手也一起提拉了？我跟你聊这个的时候是这么跟你说的，我说，我觉得这就像我的房子。我的房子是一栋老房子。好吧，你猜怎么着？凯德（Cade）的卫生间漏水了。这下得全部拆掉重做。现在凯德的卫生间看起来会棒极了。
And the rest of the house is going to look like shit. So this is what happens. You like fix up one part and then the rest that isn't working is very obvious. Yeah. It's a slippery slope. So like if I did my neck, then what about my eyebrow, my forehead? I don't know. It's a domino effect.
而房子的其他部分看起来就像一堆狗屎。所以事情就是这样。你修好了某一个部分，然后剩下的那些没修好的地方就变得极其明显。对。这会引发滑坡效应。所以，如果我做了脖子，那我的眉毛、额头怎么办？我不知道。这就是多米诺骨牌效应。
Yeah. Well, that's why I guess you have to do like it all at once. Yeah. Seems traumatic to me. Yeah. And painful. Yeah. And expensive.
是的。好吧，我想这就是为什么你得一次性把它全做了。是的。我觉得这太痛苦了。是的。而且很折磨。是的。而且很贵。
And so expensive. Yeah. I mean, for that amount of money, just retire, go off the grid. I won't be in TV. Like, who cares? I know. No kidding. My gosh. All right. Anyway, one of the things that does happen, though, is part of Ned's face mask, a clump of it falls on a shirt, and he rubs it off and where it landed, it bleaches his shirt. So now he's freaking out. This is foreshadowing for how this face mask. is going to go, by the way. So now we're going to go to City Hall. Marin Esmeralda are talking to the City Hall receptionist. They're like, okay, so there was a hearing about the bathroom closure on the 13th. This was all on the up and up, this closing of the bathroom. This was approved by a vote.
而且贵得要命。好吧，为了那么多钱，干脆退休隐居算了。我才不要上电视呢。谁在乎呢？我知道。开什么玩笑。天哪。好吧。不管怎样，不过确实发生了一件事，内德的面膜掉了一团在衬衫上，他把它揉掉，结果掉落的地方把他的衬衫给漂白了。现在他吓坏了。顺便说一句，这正是这款面膜后续走向的伏笔。所以现在我们要去市政厅了。马尔和埃斯梅拉达正在和市政厅的前台接待员谈话。她们说，好吧，13号有一场关于卫生间关闭的听证会。卫生间关闭这件事完全是公开透明的。这是通过投票批准的。
Yeah. Esmeralda is still not convinced. She sort of fakes this giant migraine and then she goes off into his office. She gets his day planner. She takes a picture of it. Yes. And she sees that he was doing a trivia night whenever this meeting took place. He was even there, this Frank Durham guy.
对。埃斯梅拉达还是不相信。她假装自己得了超级严重的偏头痛，然后溜进了他的办公室。她拿走了他的日程规划本。她拍了照片。没错。她发现这个会议举行的时候，他其实在搞冷知识问答之夜。这个叫弗兰克·达勒姆的家伙甚至根本不在那儿。
Exactly. I want to give a shout out to Leslie Thurston, who played the City Hall administrator. She was great. She studied at Groundlings. She's been a gazillion TV shows, including Parks and Rec and the Morning Show. And I've also got a little location breakdown for you. Eric said Frank Durham's office in City Hall was shot. at the Freemasons Hall in Pasadena.
没错。我要向扮演市政厅行政人员的莱斯利·瑟斯顿（Leslie Thurston）表示感谢。她演得真棒。她在格朗德林剧团（Groundlings）学习过。她演过无数部电视剧，包括《公园与游憩》和《早间新闻》。我还为你们准备了一个小小的外景解析。埃里克说，市政厅里弗兰克·达勒姆的办公室是在帕萨迪纳的共济会大厅（Freemasons Hall）拍摄的。
He went on to say, I don't want to make any enemies of the Freemasons, but I think that building is haunted. I looked it up. We were talking about conspiracies earlier. I could find nothing about the Freemasons Hall in Pasadena being haunted. But did you know, Pasadena, California is like the most haunted section of Los Angeles? They've got a gazillion buildings and parks that all have stories of being.
他接着说，我可不想跟共济会结仇，但我真心觉得那栋建筑闹鬼。我查了一下。我们刚才还在聊阴谋论呢。我找不到任何关于帕萨迪纳共济会大厅闹鬼的记录。但是你知道吗，加利福尼亚州的帕萨迪纳可以说是洛杉矶最闹鬼的区域了？他们有成百上千栋建筑和公园都有闹鬼和幽灵的传说。有一个公园据人们说有马克思兄弟（Marx Brothers）的鬼魂出没。哇。对啊。我敢说你可以去帕萨迪纳搞个鬼魂徒步之旅。你大概真的可以。我们的驾车游览路线有点分散。可以的。哦，妹子，当埃斯梅拉达向马尔展示她日程表的照片时，我能说一下我最喜欢的她的台词吗？现在她们在外面。她们在停车场。她们说，看这个。根本没有提到听证会，只有冷知识问答之夜。然后埃斯梅拉达说，没错，那种男人，他们就喜欢大声喊出事实。这真的是个非常搞笑的梗。对了，你注意到她手机上的星星贴纸，以及她车上的所有贴纸了吗？那辆车看起来像是一辆菲亚特500X（Fiat 500X）？我查过了。她的车也是红色的。
haunted and ghosts. There's this one park that people say is haunted by the Marks Brothers. Wow. Yeah. I bet you could do like a haunted walking tour of Pasadena. You probably could. Our driving tours kind of spread out. You could. Yeah. Oh, lady, can I also say my favorite Esmeralda line when she's showing mirror the pictures of her calendar? Now they're like outside. They're in the parking lot. And they're like, look at this. There's no mention of a hearing, only trivia night. And then Esmeralda says, yes, those kinds of men, they love to yell out facts. It's like a very funny thing. Well, did you notice the star sticker on her phone and all these stickers on her car, which looks like it's a Fiat 500X? I looked it up. Her car is also red.
我觉得这种红色是她身上的一个主题。她几乎总是带点红色，红色的摇摇球，衬衫上的红花，红口红，红裙子，红车。还有星星，星星，到处都是。妹子，我大概在两集以前就对这些星星着迷了。我知道，当我解析她的办公室时，我提到过它们出现在各种各样的地方。台灯上、相框上都有星星贴纸。而且它们似乎还在扩张。我觉得我一直在注意到更多。就像你说的，我在她的手机和车上也注意到了。我联系了切尔西，切尔西·弗赖（Chelsea Fry）。哦，切尔西怎么说？有什么独家内幕吗？切尔西，快跟我讲讲这些星星的事，因为我觉得这是萨布丽娜（Sabrina）的主意。嗯。
I feel like this red color is a theme for her. She almost always has a hint of red, red yo-yo, red flowers on her blouse, red lipstick, red dress, red car. And stars, stars, are everywhere. Lady, I became obsessed with these stars like two episodes ago. I know when I did a breakdown of her office, I mentioned they're on all kinds of things. There's a star sticker on the lamp, on her frame. And they seem to be expanding. I feel like I keep noticing more. And like you said, I noticed them on her phone and her car. I reached out to Chelsea, Chelsea Fry. Oh, what did Chelsea say? What's the scoop? Chelsea, talk to me about these stars because I feel like this was Sabrina. Mm-hmm.
我觉得这个红色是她的主题色。她几乎总是带有一抹红色，红色的溜溜球，衬衫上的红花，红色的口红，红色的裙子，红色的车。还有星星，星星到处都是。天哪，我大概在两集前就对这些星星着迷了。我知道当我分析她的办公室时，我提到它们出现在各种东西上。台灯上、相框上都有星星贴纸。而且它们似乎在增加。我觉得我不断注意到更多。就像你说的，我注意到她的手机和车上也有。我联系了切尔西，切尔西·弗莱。哦，切尔西说了什么？有什么内幕？切尔西，跟我说说这些星星的事，因为我觉得这就是萨布丽娜。嗯哼。
Can you find out, was it her, was it set decoration? It's so specific. Chelsea was like, I'm on it. So here's what she found out. Sabrina said it started with an email between herself and set decoration, just talking about what Esmeralda's office might look like. And Sabrina had really wanted the office to look personalized. So she brought in this sticker tape of stars.
你能查出来这是她弄的，还是布景部门弄的吗？这太具体了。切尔西当时就说，包在我身上。所以她是这么查出来的。萨布丽娜说，这始于她和布景部门之间的一封邮件，大家在讨论埃斯梅拉达的办公室应该长什么样。萨布丽娜非常希望办公室看起来能有个性化。所以她带了这种星星贴纸带。
Okay. Because Sabrina herself has always loved stars, and she thought this was a really good overlap with her character. So they just let her start putting these stars wherever she wanted, and she stuck them on everything, including the car. Sabrina stuck them on the car. There's so many. They like outline her window, her driver's door. So did she stick one or two on the car? And then set deck was like, okay, we'll take it from here?
好吧。因为萨布丽娜本人一直很喜欢星星，她觉得这与她的角色非常契合。所以他们就让她开始把这些星星贴在她想贴的任何地方，她把它们贴在了所有东西上，包括车上。萨布丽娜把它们贴在了车上。有超多。它们勾勒出她车窗、驾驶室车门的轮廓。所以她是只在车上贴了一两个吗？然后布景部门就说，好吧，接下来交给我们？
No, I think she did it. I mean, I'm not 100% sure, but Chelsea was like, no, no, no, Sabrina stuck the stars on the car. Holy crap. I know. Isn't that crazy? I also have to point out something else from this scene. Did you notice that Maher's phone screen was cracked? They FaceTime Ned to tell him about this find.
不，我觉得是她自己贴的。我是说，我不是百分之百确定，但切尔西说，不不不，星星是萨布丽娜贴在车上的。天哪。我知道。是不是很疯狂？我必须指出这场戏里的另一个细节。你注意到马尔的手机屏幕碎了吗？他们跟内德视频通话，告诉他这个发现。
And I just love it that little detail that Mary's screen is cracked. She hasn't fixed it. It's so relatable. I know. Well, I also wanted to point out, since they're filming outside, it's in a parking lot. We've filmed outside in parking lots in the summer in Los Angeles. They're dressed in jackets and winterwear. And Eric shared with us that the week they filmed this episode, it was crazy hot with temperatures over 100 degrees. Oh my gosh. Yeah. And he said that he and Jason Walliner, the director of
我太喜欢马尔手机屏幕碎了这个小细节了。她还没去修。这太真实了。我知道。嗯，我还想指出一点，因为他们是在外面拍摄，是在一个停车场。我们在洛杉矶夏天的停车场外面拍过戏。他们穿着夹克和冬装。埃里克跟我们分享说，他们拍这一集的那周热得要命，气温超过了100华氏度（约38摄氏度）。哦，天哪。对啊。他说他和这一集的导演贾森·沃利纳（Jason Walliner）
this episode, they decided to do a food truck that week, right? Yeah, so nice. So nice for the crew, for everyone. And they picked a Poutine truck. What's Poutine? How would you have it? I mean, it's like French fries with like stuff on it, like gravy and cheese curds. But the gravy is like hot. Okay. Yeah, they have those in Amsterdam too. Yeah. Okay. He said this poutine truck arrived on the hottest day of the year. He said so people were having to eat hot duck gravy over French fries and like triple digit weather. Yum. He said, not great. Well, it's getting close to the end of the day, and Ned has gathered most of the staff into his office. And it is revealed that he has burned his face from this face mask thing. He also started taking everyone else's products. Like, he went overboard. Yeah, because they were like, we can't do this anymore.
决定在那周搞一辆餐车，对吧？对，太棒了。对剧组每个人都太好了。他们挑了一辆普丁（Poutine，肉汁奶酪薯条）餐车。什么是普丁？你会怎么吃它？我是说，这就像法式薯条上面浇了东西，比如肉汁和干酪块。但肉汁是热的。好吧。对，他们在阿姆斯特丹也有这种吃的。好吧。他说这辆普丁餐车在一年中最热的那天到了。他说所以人们不得不在华氏上百度的天气里，吃着浇在炸薯条上的热鸭肉汁。真香。他说，感觉不太好。好吧，接近一天结束了，内德把大部分员工召集到了他的办公室。据透露，他的脸被那个面膜给灼伤了。他还开始拿走所有其他人的产品。就像，他玩过头了。对，因为他们当时觉得，我们再也受不了了。
They were bailing. Yes, and he was like, I'm going to do everything. Lady, watching him put that lighted, chin strap over his burned face and then drinking the kombucha. It was like wound on wound for you. It was the same as someone getting punched in a wound. It really... I thought about you.
他们都想溜了。没错，而他却说，我要把所有东西都试一遍。妹子，看着他把那个带灯光的下巴束带戴在他被灼伤的脸上，然后又喝了那个康普茶。对你来说简直是伤口上撒盐。这跟有人往伤口上打拳一模一样。真的……我当时就想到你了。
Thank you. Well, now we're at the bar. I mean, Mare's going to go undercover. Esmeralda has given her a makeover in the bathroom. She looks amazing. Do you think that is one of Esmeralda's dresses? Yes. This was my question.
谢谢。好吧，现在我们来到酒吧了。我是说，马尔要去做卧底了。埃斯梅拉达在卫生间里给她来了个大改造。她看起来棒极了。你觉得那是埃斯梅拉达的裙子吗？是的。这就是我的问题。
I totally do. It looks like Mare is wearing an Esmeralda dress. It's got kind of the Esmeralda belt. look to it. Ned shows up. He's like, why is she dressed like that? And as Marlda says, she's undercover as a beautiful woman. I know.
我完全觉得是。马尔看起来就像穿着一条埃斯梅拉达的裙子。它甚至有点埃斯梅拉达的腰带风格。内德出现了。他说，她怎么穿成这样？埃斯梅拉达说，她这是在伪装成一个美女。我知道。
And Mare is working at, man. She got Frank to confirm that he does do trivia every Tuesday night, including the 13th. This is very exciting. Very exciting. They're exposing him. I was curious about popular trivia game nights at bars. What about them? Well, I've never been to one.
而且马尔正在干活，伙计。她成功让弗兰克承认他确实每周二晚上都去玩冷知识问答，包括13号那天。这太让人兴奋了。太令人兴奋了。他们在揭发他。我对酒吧里流行的冷知识问答之夜很好奇。怎么个好奇法？嗯，我从来没去过。
And you know what? I found a website. called Best Trivia Ever, and it lists different trivia themes and trivia night schedules nationwide. They're very popular. They're so popular. But, lady, I didn't realize how many different types of genres. I mean, obviously, there's sports, movies, books, musicians, animation, television. I mean, we know there's an office one.
你知道吗？我找到一个叫“史上最佳冷知识”（Best Trivia Ever）的网站，上面列出了全国各地不同的冷知识主题和冷知识之夜的日程表。它们非常受欢迎。它们太受欢迎了。但是，妹子，我以前没意识到有这么多不同的流派。显然，有体育、电影、书籍、音乐家、动画、电视。我是说，我们知道有个《办公室》主题的。
Yeah. There's also, like, eras. Like, there's 90s night, 80s nights trivia. But listen to some of these categories. I just want to read you a few. They sound like so much fun to me. Action movie trivia night. Celebrity couples trivia night.
对。还有那种，按年代分的。比如有90年代之夜、80年代之夜的冷知识。但听听其中一些分类。我只想读几个给你们听。我觉得它们听起来太好玩了。动作电影冷知识之夜。名人情侣冷知识之夜。
Stoner movie trivia night. Okay. It's all movies where they think people get stoned. Or are they movies you watch when you're stoned? I think there are movies where people are stoned. I feel like it's both. Could be. Next one, Nicholas Cage Trivia Night.
迷幻电影冷知识之夜。好吧。这全都是人们吸了毒之后的电影。还是说这是你磕大了的时候看的电影？我觉得这是人们嗑嗨了的电影。我觉得两者皆有可能。有可能。下一个，尼古拉斯·凯奇冷知识之夜。
Is there a Keanu one? I'm sure there is. And Sam, there's an Emily and Paris trivia night. Good. You would destroy that night. Anyway, I just was very tickled, but there's so many types. We've been talking forever about doing one.
有没有基努（Keanu）专场？我确信肯定有。萨姆，还有一个《艾米丽在巴黎》冷知识之夜。不错。你在这个专场绝对能大杀四方。不管怎样，我只是觉得太逗了，居然有这么多类型。我们俩讨论要搞一个已经讨论一万年了。
We never do it. I mean, which one would you do? I don't think we can do the office one. I wouldn't do well in the office one unless we got my friend, who I did Ashland Avenue with, Will, who won the National Office Trivia contest. Well, I think we would have to take Will and Billy I. And then also from Boy Meets World, we'd need to take Will Friedel. He has a photographic memory.
但我们从来没办过。我是说，你会选哪个？我觉得我们不能办《办公室》主题的。我在《办公室》那个专场表现不会好，除非我们带上我的朋友——跟我一起演过阿什兰大街（Ashland Avenue）的威尔（Will），他赢过全国《办公室》冷知识大赛。嗯，我觉得我们必须带上威尔和比利·I。然后还要从《男孩成长记》（Boy Meets World）剧组带上威尔·弗里德尔（Will Friedel）。他有摄影般的记忆力。
Well, then we would win. Then we would win. But non-office trivia night, I would do good at a horror movie trivia night. They have that genre. I think I could do really well. Yeah. Although I'm not up on a lot of the more recent horror films. I could do like horror films in history.
那我们就赢定了。那我们就赢定了。但如果是非《办公室》的冷知识之夜，我在恐怖电影冷知识之夜肯定能表现不错。他们有这个流派。我觉得我能答得很好。虽然我对很多近期的恐怖片不太了解。我大概能搞定历史上的恐怖片。
Yeah. I mean, we might do well at like 80s or 90s pop culture. Right? Sam, have you seen primate? No, I haven't. Is it good? I don't know. What's it?
对。我是说，我们在80年代或90年代流行文化方面可能表现不错。对吧？萨姆，你看过《灵长类动物》（Primate）吗？没有，我没看过。好看吗？我不知道。讲什么的？
It's a horror movie, right? It's about primates that take over? It's about a single pet chimp that turns. I mean, this is a total fear of mine. I mean, you shouldn't be that afraid. I don't think you're ever going to have a pet chimp. Well, you guys know I've had so many monkeys. There's so many ways to avoid this scenario.
这是部恐怖片，对吧？讲的是灵长类动物接管一切？讲的是一只变成怪物的宠物黑猩猩。我是说，这是我极其恐惧的一点。我是说，你没必要那么害怕。我觉得你永远也不会养一只宠物黑猩猩。好吧，你们知道我养过好多猴子。有很多方法可以避免这种剧本。
I've had so many monkeys attack me. You know this. No, I don't. Come on. I did an open mic night. I wasn't there? When monkeys. attack me. I've talked about this. This is the title. When monkeys attack me. It's very funny.
我有过被好多猴子袭击的经历。你知道的。不，我不知道。得了吧。我搞过开放麦之夜。我不在场吗？当猴子袭击我的时候。我聊过这个。这就是标题。当猴子袭击我。太搞笑了。
That's great. Yes. Are you still doing it? Can I still come see it? No. It was like an improv night. And when you got a suggestion about, it was actually monkeys was a suggestion. And I was like, well, well, I knew that one-armed monkey attacked you, your friend's one-arm. Yes. Yes, Becky's one-arm monkey. It was a gibbon monkey. Okay, this was the 70s in Indonesia. And some people had monkeys as pets. My family did not. But Becky, had rescued this one-armed gibbon, and they built an enclosure for it. And she brought me inside it to meet the monkey. And then it started kind of going through the hair on my arm, like looking for bugs. And Becky laughed, and I swatted at her like, ha, stop it. When I swatted at her,
太棒了。对啊。你现在还在做吗？我还能去看吗？没有。那是类似即兴喜剧之夜。当你得到一个建议时，其实“猴子”就是一个建议。然后我就想，好吧，我知道那只独臂猴子袭击过你，你朋友的那只独臂……对。对，贝基（Becky）的那只独臂猴子。那是一只长臂猿。好吧，那是70年代的印度尼西亚。有些人把猴子当宠物养。我们家没有。但贝基救了一只独臂长臂猿，他们为它建了一个围栏。她把我带进里面去见那只猴子。然后它开始有点像在找虫子那样，翻找我胳膊上的头发。贝基笑了，我拍了她一下，说，哈，别闹了。当我拍她的时候，
this monkey loved Becky, the monkey freaked out, started to bite me. I had a little light jacket on, started to bite me through my jacket. And then after that, whenever I was there, it would swing by the kitchen nook, they had a window, and it would open its legs and piss on the window every time it saw me. But there's more than that? You've been attacked by more monkeys than that? We went to, when I was in elementary school in Indonesia, you know the word orangutang tang in Indonesian is orangutan, which means person of the forest, orangutan.
这只猴子很喜欢贝基，那只猴子吓坏了，开始咬我。我当时穿着一件轻便夹克，它开始透过我的夹克咬我。在那之后，每当我到那儿，它就会荡到厨房角落的窗户旁，它们有一扇窗户，然后它每次看到我都会张开腿往窗户上撒尿。但这还不止这些？你被比这更多的猴子袭击过？我们去过，我还在印度尼西亚上小学的时候，你知道“红毛猩猩”这个词在印尼语里是orangutang，意思是森林里的人，orangutan。
So we went to this orangutan sanctuary sale. I'm laughing because you assume the listener knows so much. No, I didn't know that. Of course, I didn't know that. Exactly. I'm like, why would I know that? Anyway, we go to this sanctuary and they have this big mama orangutangangang. And they're letting these like second and third graders, they go up and you get to hold her hand and you take a picture.
所以我们去了这个红毛猩猩保护区特卖会。我笑是因为你假设听众懂得太多了。不，我不知道。我当然不知道了。没错。我心想，我怎么可能会知道？不管怎样，我们去了这个保护区，那里有一只巨大的红毛猩猩妈妈。他们让这些二三年级的学生走过去，你可以握住它的手拍张照。
Uh-oh. First of all, we're like the same size because I'm in second grade and I'm tiny. Maybe I was first grade. Anyway, she holds my hand. and she just starts swinging my arm, like swinging my arm, and then she swung up and then went, boom, and I face-planted. Like, she swung up. Like, slipped you over? Like, on my face.
噢哦。首先，我们俩差不多高，因为我上二年级，而且我个子很小。也许我上的是一年级。不管怎样，她握住我的手，然后她就开始甩我的手臂，就像甩我的手臂一样，然后她往上一荡，然后发出“轰”的一声，我的脸就着地了。就像，她往上一荡。就像把你掀翻了？就像脸朝下摔在地上。
And, but, like, she was so happy. Like, it was, like, I don't know. Anyway, so orang-a-tang-tang-tang-fac-planted me. Is there another one? There can't be a third one. There's a third one. Rule of threes. So, okay, I had the one-arm-gibbon bite me.
但是，就像，她太开心了。就像是，我不知道。不管怎样，红毛猩猩妈妈让我脸朝下摔了个狗吃屎。还有别的吗？总不能还有第三次吧。还有第三次。事不过三。所以，好吧，我被独臂长臂猿咬过。
Mama orangutangang face plant me. And then I was in Indonesia. Years later, I was older, and I was at Uluatu, which is this beautiful temple on the ocean. But there are monkeys everywhere. And they say to you, the monkeys are Nakal, which means they're kind of like mischievous, right? Sure. And so you have to like be careful, don't wear glasses, water bottles, no earrings, nothing dangling because they'll just jump on you and take them. I had these tiniest hoop earrings.
被红毛猩猩妈妈弄得脸朝地。然后我在印度尼西亚。多年以后，我长大了，我在乌鲁瓦图（Uluatu），那是海边一座美丽的寺庙。但到处都是猴子。他们跟你说，这些猴子是Nakal，意思是它们有点调皮捣蛋，对吧？当然。所以你必须小心，不要戴眼镜，不要拿水瓶，不要戴耳环，什么都不能挂在身上，因为它们会直接跳到你身上抢走。我当时戴着最小的耳环。
They're so tiny. Like the kind that don't even leave room for your skin, you know, they're just flat to your earlobe. Sure. So I thought that doesn't dangle. I'm standing there. I'm looking out at the ocean. I'm like, oh, this is so beautiful.
它们太小了。就像那种甚至不给你的皮肤留出空隙的款式，你知道的，它们就贴在你的耳垂上。当然。所以我想那个不会晃荡。我站在那儿。我看着大海。心想，噢，这太美了。
There's a monkey in the tree. It literally torpedo jumps onto my shoulder and rips the earring out of my ear. Oh, my God. And I, and I didn't. It just popped right out. but I literally turned into the most southern person. I was like, oh, my Lord! And then it had my earring up in the tree, and it was kind of like gnawing on my earring.
树上有一只猴子。它 literalmente（字面意思）像鱼雷一样跳到我的肩膀上，把耳环从我耳朵上扯了下来。哦，天哪。而且我，我还没反应过来。它就“啪”地一下被扯下来了。但我直接变成了最纯正的南方人。我当时说，哦，我的天哪！然后它把我的耳环挂在树上，开始在那儿啃我的耳环。
And this guy that was kind of guiding everyone through the temple, he had these little bananas. And he traded. He looked at the monkey and he was like, you want a banana? And the monkey's like, you want this earring? And they went back and forth. And then they traded. And I got my earring back. Oh, so you think the monkey knew to do that to get a banana?
然后那个带大家参观寺庙的导游拿了几个小香蕉。他去做了交换。他看着那只猴子说，你想要香蕉吗？那只猴子说，你想要这个耳环吗？他们俩你来我往地比划。然后他们交换了。我把我的耳环拿回来了。哦，所以你觉得那只猴子知道这么做能换到香蕉？
I don't know. I mean, here's my thing about these three. incidents. Yes, they all involve primates. Yes. They also all involve Indonesia. And there's a lot of primates. And human error. Well, there are also in sanctuary. All three of these weren't monkeys who should have been near in any scenario. Well, the temple, they're everywhere. So if you go to a temple anywhere, anywhere in Bali, the monkeys are there and you leave them alone. It's their temple. I mean, that's their area, you know. So you don't.
我不知道。我是说，关于这三起事件，我的看法是。没错，它们都涉及灵长类动物。没错。它们也都发生在印度尼西亚。而且有大量的灵长类动物。还有人为错误。好吧，而且都在保护区里。这三次都不是那种根本不应该在任何情况下靠近的猴子。好吧，在寺庙里，它们到处都是。所以无论你去哪里的寺庙，在巴厘岛的任何地方，猴那是它们的地盘，你得离它们远点。那是它们的寺庙。我是说，那是它们的领地，你知道的。所以你不要去
mess with them, but they're everywhere. Anyway, I don't know how we got off on that. You asked him if he saw a primate. I just asked if he'd seen the horror film primate. Anyway, I'm convinced, let's say you had a chimpanzee and I went over. I mean, it's coming for me. I'm never going to have one. Well, I'm just convinced that monkeys, like, I am not getting around a monkey.
招惹它们，但它们无处不在。不管怎样，我不知道我们怎么扯到这上面去了。你问他有没有看到灵长类动物。我只是问他有没有看过恐怖片《灵长类动物》。不管怎样，我确信，假设你养了一只黑猩猩，然后我走过去。我是说，它是冲着我来的。我永远也不会养一只。好吧，我只是确信猴子，就像，我绝不会靠近猴子。
It's coming for me. I mean, I have not a single monkey story. Yeah, your ability to drop such deep Angela lore, so casual. is one of my favorite things about you. You've never mentioned this before. I swear, I thought you guys knew this in all these years about all the monkeys. I actually have more.
它是冲着我来的。我是说，我连一个关于猴子的故事都没有。对啊，你轻描淡写地抛出这么深度的安吉拉冷知识的能力，真的是我最喜欢你的地方之一。你以前从来没提过这个。我发誓，我以为你们这些年来一直都知道这些关于猴子的事。其实我还有更多。
I'll save it for another day. I can't believe there's more. I look forward to it. Well, this was a tangent. It's a true classic tangent. Well, I've got a fact. Do you want me to bring us back to the episode with a little fact?
我留着改天再说。真不敢相信还有更多。我拭目以待。好吧，这跑题跑得有点远。这绝对是一次经典跑题。好吧，我有个冷知识。你想让我用一个小冷知识把大家带回正题吗？
I'm sure everybody wants you to bring this back. Everyone listening right now is like, good Lord. All right. Well, listen, when Ned shows up at this bar, his face is like peeling off in huge sections. It's like red. It's flaking off. And I was really curious, how did they do this? Because we know that this would have been like an elaborate makeup test. And it also would have had to have continuity. Yes. Like, okay, this is the fifth hour into this face mask. What does that look like? And it does. His face progresses. It gets worse and worse. So I reached out to Kelly Cantley, who put me in touch with Autumn Butler, the makeup artist for this episode. Thank you so much, Kelly. And Autumn said this was a very fun makeup to design and that Greg
我敢说每个人都想让你把我们带回正题。现在听节目的每个人都在想，天哪。好吧，听着，当内德出现在这家酒吧时，他的脸像大片大片地脱落一样。红通通的。还在起皮。我真的很好奇，他们是怎么做到的？因为我们知道这肯定是一次精心制作的妆容测试。而且还得连戏。对吧，比如，这是敷这个面膜的第五个小时。那会是什么样子？确实如此。他的脸一直在恶化。情况变得越来越糟。所以我联系了凯莉·坎特利（Kelly Cantley），她把我介绍给这一集的化妆师奥特姆·巴特勒（Autumn Butler）。非常感谢凯莉。奥特姆说，设计这个妆容非常有趣，而且格雷格·
Daniels had very specific ideas. Greg definitely did not want it to look or feel like an actual condition that somebody would really have in real life. He didn't want anyone to feel like they were being made fun of about any actual real-life problem they might be experiencing. He also wanted it to feel very, as Autumn put it, charismaticly comedic. So Autumn said they tested this makeup for two days to find the perfect look and texture. Greg really wanted it to look like a snake
丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）有非常具体的想法。格雷格绝对不想让它看起来或感觉像某种真人在现实生活中会得的真实病情。他不想让任何人觉得他们是在被取笑现实生活中可能正在经历的任何真实问题。他还希望它感觉非常——正如奥特姆所说——具有滑稽的个人魅力。所以奥特姆说他们测试了两天这个妆容，以找到完美的妆效和质感。格雷格真的希望它看起来像一条蛇
that was like molting and shedding in sheets and layers. Oh, it does look like that by the end. He also wanted pieces that could be peeled away. way on camera. So they had to create both this makeup that was on his face and also this interactive piece. So Autumn said first they tried it with silicone. They tried melted pieces of bald caps. They tried latex strips, but nothing was giving the right feel. So in the end, she created a mixture of Elmer's glue and duo applied to his face in really thin
在蜕皮，成片成层地脱落。哦，到最后看起来确实是这样。他还想要那些可以在镜头前被撕下来的碎片。所以他们必须同时创造出他脸上的这种妆容以及这种互动式的道具。所以奥特姆说，他们首先尝试用硅胶。他们尝试过融化的秃头帽碎片。他们尝试过乳胶条，但没有一种能带来正确的感觉。所以在最后，她用埃尔默胶水（Elmer's glue）和Duo双眼皮胶混合，分非常薄的层涂在他的脸上，
layers, and then they scrunched up his face and started peeling portions off. She said it was like a total old-fashioned arts and crafts project. I mean, how was his skin in real life? I didn't ask her. I mean, he's wearing glue.
然后他们把他的脸挤成一团，开始把一部分一部分地撕下来。她说这完全就像是一个老式的工艺美术项目。我是说，他现实生活中的皮肤怎么样？我没问她。我是说，他涂了胶水。
But she said they also made sheets of fake skin with that same Elmer's lash glue mixture, and they spread it out on wax paper, and then they let it dry, and then they would peel that off, and those were the pieces that they would use, like, they would just attach it very slightly to his skin, and then that would be the piece that he, like, pulled off interactively. And then Eric said, he remembered the test process for this whole thing. He said it was very thorough.
但她说他们还用同样的埃尔默睫毛胶混合物制作了假皮肤片，把它铺在蜡纸上，然后让他们晾干，接着他们会把那些撕下来，那些就是他们要用的碎片，比如，他们会把它们非常轻微地贴在他的皮肤上，然后这就成了他可以像互动那样拉扯下来的碎片。然后埃里克说，他记得整个过程的测试流程。他说非常彻底。
He remembered Autumn from makeup, hired somebody. to do the test makeup. Isn't that a crazy job? Yeah. You get hired to just come in and let them test stuff on you. I mean, yeah. Yeah. So anyway, Eric said that Autumn brought this guy into the writer's room.
他记得来自化妆部的奥特姆雇了个人来做测试妆。这不是一份很疯狂的工作吗？对啊。你被雇来只是为了过来让他们在你身上测试各种东西。我是说，对啊。对啊。所以不管怎样，埃里克说奥特姆把这个家伙带到了编剧室。
He thinks it was like four times before Greg approved the makeup. Look how much went into this one gag. I know. Wow. Eric also said if I were net, I would have gone to the hospital if my skin looked like that. But I understand he's just very passionate about journalism. Yeah. Well, we do find out that in the end, his skin ends up looking amazing.
他觉得大概有四次之多，格雷格才批准了这个妆容。看看这一个小包袱花费了多少心血。我觉得太惊艳了。哇。埃里克还说，如果我是内德，我的皮肤要是长成那样，我早就去医院了。但我理解他只是对新闻工作充满热情。对。好吧，我们确实发现在最后，他的皮肤看起来好极了。
The next day, he's like glowing. Glowing. It comes around. And just to keep throwing facts at you, I have a location breakdown for the macaroni barn. First of all, there's no macaroni barn in Toledo, Ohio, but there is a spaghetti warehouse. Coincidence? Inspired by? Perhaps.
第二天，他整个人神采奕奕。神采奕奕。情况好转了。为了继续向你们抛出冷知识，我还有一个关于“通心粉 barn（Macaroni Barn）”的外景解析。首先，俄亥俄州托莱多并没有通心粉 barn，但确实有一个“意大利面仓库（Spaghetti Warehouse）”。纯属巧合？受到启发？也许吧。
Eric shared that the interior and exterior of the macaroni barn were two different places. We've done that before. We did that with poor Richards on the office. The interior of macaroni barn was shot at the smokehouse next to the universal lot. And the exterior is actually a faky front restaurant on the universal lot right across from the high school, from back to the future. So if you go on the little universal bus tour, you could see it. So the following morning, we do have this little wrap-up scene between Ken and Adam. I just loved Ken in this episode.
埃里克分享说，通心粉 barn 的内部和外部是两个不同的地方。我们以前干过这种事。我们在《办公室》拍“穷理查德酒吧”时就这么干过。通心粉 barn 的内部是在环球影城外景地旁边的烟屋（Smokehouse）拍摄的。而外部其实是环球影城外景地上一家假的餐厅门面，就在《回到未来》里那个高中对面。所以如果你去坐环球影城的露天小巴观光游，就能看到它。所以在接下来的早晨，肯和亚当之间确实有这么一小段收尾戏。我太喜欢这一集里的肯了。
I get why Eric loved writing for him. Ken says, how are you feeling? More importantly, did you make mad, ravenous scorpion love to your wife? We find out from Adam, they did it like three times. And Ken's like, wow, three times, big man, love that. And then Adam's like, maybe they were just sugar pills because three times is pretty standard for us. I mean, no wonder he has four kids.
我懂为什么埃里克喜欢为他写台词了。肯说，感觉怎么样？更重要的是，你对你老婆进行疯狂、狂热的蝎子式做爱了吗？我们从亚当那里得知，他们做了差不多三次。然后肯说，哇，三次，大人物，我喜欢。接着亚当说，也许它们只是糖丸，因为对我们来说三次相当标准。我是说，难怪他有四个孩子。
No wonder. Snip, snap, Adam. And then we have a little hint at maybe a romance. Between who? Ned and Mare. He clearly thought she looked beautiful, but he was like, listen, I'm sorry of Esmeralda made you dress up like that. I know that's not something you like.
难怪。咔哒，咔哒，亚当。然后我们看到了可能会有浪漫情愫的小苗头。谁和谁？内德和马尔。他显然觉得她看起来很美，但他说，听着，如果埃斯梅拉达让你穿成那样，我很抱歉。我知道这不是你喜欢的事。
She's like, what are you talking about? I like dressing up. And he was like, yeah, but you know, you're asexual. also. And she was like, why would you think that? And then he's like, Esmeralda. And he's so ticked off. He's like, Esmeralda, you told me. And Maris like, it doesn't matter what she told you. What kind of journalists are you? You didn't even ask me? You didn't even follow up? But I mean, he's her boss. How can he go to her and ask her about her sexuality? He's not allowed to do that. I know. So it's like, I get it. Like, I thought it was cool of him to be like, hey, listen, I hope that
她说，你在说什么？我喜欢盛装打扮。然后他说，对啊，但你知道的，你也是无性恋。然后她说，你怎么会这么想？接着他说，埃斯梅拉达。他气坏了。他说，埃斯梅拉达，你告诉我的。马尔说，她告诉你什么根本不重要。你算什么记者？你甚至都没问过我？你甚至都没跟进调查？但我是说，他是她的老板。他怎么能去找她并打听她的性取向？他不被允许这么做。我知道。所以这就好比，我懂的。我觉得他这么说挺酷的，就像是，嘿，听着，我希望
whole thing didn't put you in an uncomfortable situation. In general, you shouldn't have to be, you know, flirting with men and sources in order to get, you know, a story. And I just, you know, he was trying to be appropriate. He was. Well, this episode ends with the Ned talking head. He's just perplexed. He's like, why is she mad at me? Some people are just sensitive. And then he's like, she didn't even notice how revitalized I look. Exactly. And that's the end of the episode, everybody. Thank you to everyone who sent in their around the towns and to Darby for our chit-chat. Yes. And also a big thank you to Eric Rayhill, Kelly Cantley, Autumn Butler, Sabrina and Patchettori, and Chelsea Fry for some great behind-the-scenes nuggets on this one. Great. Before we go, I have something for you guys. Don't say it's a monkey. No. Okay. He goes,
整件事没有把你置于一个尴尬的境地。一般来说，为了搞到新闻，你本不应该去跟男人和消息源调情的。而且我只是，你知道的，他是在试图表现得体。他是的。好吧，这一集在内德的面对镜头独白中结束了。他简直一头雾水。他说，她生我气干嘛？有些人就是太敏感了。然后他说，她甚至都没注意到我看起来多么焕发青春。没错。这就是这一集的结尾啦，各位。感谢所有发来“漫步小镇”信件的人，感谢达比（Darby）跟我们闲聊。对的。还要非常感谢埃里克·雷希尔（Eric Rayhill）、凯莉·坎特利、奥特姆·巴特勒、萨布丽娜和帕切托里（Patchettori），以及切尔西·弗赖，为这一集提供了许多精彩的幕后趣闻。太棒了。在离开之前，我给你们准备了个东西。别说是猴子。不。好吧。他说，
at the end of a Christmas carol, he opens the door and he goes, what day is today? And he goes, today it's Christmas day. I wanted that to have this energy. Okay. Around the town. We have around the town. Thanks, Sam. Yep. You were working on that while we were doing that episode. Oh, I love that.
在《圣诞颂歌》的结尾，他打开门说，今天是几号？然后他说，今天是圣诞节。我希望这能有那种能量。好吧。漫步小镇。我们有漫步小镇。谢谢你，萨姆。没错。我们在拍那一集的时候你就在弄这个了。哦，我太喜欢这个了。
All right, you guys. Well, we hope you have a great week. We appreciate you all, and we'll see you next time. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
好了，各位。嗯，我们希望你们过个愉快的一周。感谢大家，我们下期再见。回头见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”是Audyssey呈现的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle）。
Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubico）。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。“办公室女士”由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Shultz）进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Ruppertry》。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。